Senate Minority Leader that's Chuck
Schumer joins us now from the capital he
voted against President Clinton's
impeachment 21 years ago today Senator
Schumer thank you so much for joining us
let's take a look at the big picture for
a second if we can listeners the
Democrats voted mostly along party lines
the Senate is expected to do the same we
keep hearing and seeing that the public
is really getting tired of this whole
process so how do you convince how do
you convey to a very very public that
this is really based on principle and
not partisanship what's your strategy
for that it seems like you need one
well impeachment is a very very somber
process it's one of the few powers of
somber a serious and important power to
stop an overreaching president and there
is no doubt this president has
overreached he's the most overreaching
president we've had and so the Senate
has always been lodged with the
responsibility to be impartial jurors
and judge this and in previous
impeachments that has happened and so we
want to make it that way again and I
think the American people are behind us
for instance I've asked Leader McConnell
for four witnesses these are witnesses
who had uh who actually saw what
happened and can speak directly to the
charges brought against the president
there's a lot of good evidence the house
has come up with but this would be even
better
well 64 said well can't wait 64 percent
of the American people of Republicans
and 72% of the American people say there
ought to be witnesses and so we are
gonna ask for those that that is fair
senator can you get that we cannot let
we cannot yes can you get the votes to
make that happen can you get a vote to
make that up in a process like this
justice and history way on shoulders in
different ways and our Republican
colleagues leader McConnell may be
totally partisan he may wish to make
this impeachment in tuition trial into a
sham
but there are many Republican colleagues
and many of them are wondering about
this thinking about this and this kind
of serious consequence weighs on
shoulders in different ways there are
three weeks in the next few weeks as
they go home and think about the
seriousness and there is no good answer
as to why we shouldn't have witnesses
McConnell has ranted and raved but he
hasn't had a single direct answer why
there shouldn't be witnesses I think we
will get witnesses and one more point
here I don't know what these witnesses
will say they could you know they're all
appointees of President Trump they could
be exculpatory and that so be it if they
are so that truth should come out and we
are pushing to get the truth not a sham
trial where nothing new is learned so
senator on that point Mitch McConnell
has said openly he is not an impartial
juror this is a political process can
you stand here today and say that you
are impartial that your mind is open yes
and that's why we're asking for these
witnesses as I said these witnesses
could well issue statements that are
exculpatory Mitch McConnell must get the
truth and leader McConnell is hiding the
truth you know what the American people
are asking in reference to Gail's
question what is the president hiding
what is leader McConnell hiding if they
don't want these witnesses who are
directly dispositive on the case to come
before us Mitch McConnell has accused
you of not meeting with him and
negotiating through the press you've
certainly been on TV a lot lately when
do you plan to meet with him and what do
you hope to get out of it well two weeks
ago Mitch McConnell again has twisted
the truth two weeks ago I went to him
and I said I'm ready to meet whenever
you are he hasn't asked instead he's
done several things long before I went
public he went on Sean Hannity not a
very private act and said he is going to
take orders from the president he issued
his own plan to his Republican caucus
and publicly so of course we countered
with the public plan but people should
judge what we're asking for on the
merits and the merits have no good
argument against having witnesses and
donkey
why don't you folks name me one I
haven't heard one from a single
Republican you can't senator two
Democrats there were two Democratic
defections in the house vote to impeach
are you expecting any defections in the
Senate
look our caucus is unified behind
getting these documents and our caucus
is going to give this a serious look
most of our members have not come to
conclusions the way Leader McConnell has
and so yes I expect that my colleagues
regard these charges is very serious
they're going to hear the evidence
hopefully we'll get that evidence with
witnesses and documents and everyone
will render a decision all right senator
schumer thank you so much for being with
us this morning thank you very much